hugh grant is doctor who
really
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so as we know jodie whitaker is leaving
her role as doctor who and i think it's
a shame because actually i think she was
great but i think she think
doctor who has suffered over the last
couple years because of bad writing not
because of a bad doctor but anyway new
showrunner new big project bbc seem to
be really trying to put a bit of weight
behind this new doctor who
one way you could really get behind this
is actually putting in an actor to be
the new doctor who that is generally
pretty well loved and the rumor is it's
going to be hugh grant
now hugh grant has come out and actually
denied this and said it's a load of
rubbish it's not happening so this rumor
won't go away it keeps persisting and
then major british newspaper today it's
been reported the talks have already
begun i'd say even though hugh grant is
saying not a chance there seems to be
some weight behind this in this room it
seems to be gathering momentum it was
actually reported on bbc one yesterday
so is this a rumor that's got any weight
to it
i put a poll on the community page of
sidetrack and to be honest it's only
been on a couple of hours we've got
plenty of votes and the public seem to
be behind this
hugh grant is actually
quite liked actor in the uk he's done
some amazing projects but his career has
been on a little bit of a downward trend
over the last few years the big product
with him being paddington and this sort
of thing he's not getting the big
hollywood movies he once did so is this
something in the twilight of his career
that he would consider
eccleston did the first doctor who and
the big new rebrand when it came back on
our screens a few years ago he only did
one year but he is a big movie star
actor
they were able to talk him into it maybe
they could talk hugh grant into it also
the doctor who has a worldwide following
it is seen in the us as well as the uk
and it is a very popular following the
actors like david tennant and matt smith
who did doctor who well went on to have
excellent careers and maybe this maybe
hugh grant is seeing this not as a step
down but actually as something fun to
reignite his career in other ways the
other point is actually hugh grant was
offered this a few years ago and he did
turn it down at the time but maybe this
is just the opportunity for a second
chance
i don't know if this rumor has any
weight
but i have to say honestly hand on heart
if hugh grant got this role i would
watch doctor who again and i haven't
watched doctor who definitely under jody
whitaker and i didn't watch it before
that because i haven't really watched it
since matt smith left
but i would definitely watch it again a
few grant was the doctor he also has a
cheeky style of acting that i could
completely see working for this role my
instinct i have to admit was that
wouldn't work it would be stupid but the
more i think about it the more i think
that little glint in his eye that hugh
grant has that slightly naughty
british gentleman wrong could actually
work really really well for doctor who
so
if he's willing and if he can
if the bbc basically are willing to put
enough money into it maybe this is
something that could work
so get into comments tell me what do you
think do you think it's just one of
those stupid rumors do you think hugh
grant would even be any good as the
doctor or do you think the rumor keeps
building momentum because secretly they
are in talks and hugh grant has only
said no because you know it's a
negotiation tactic
let me know exactly what you think and
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out also
you could become a fully fledged
sidetracker and support the channel
please consider hitting the join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you soon